(chants et tambours)
- L'ambiance, dès le début de
la journée, était plutôt légère
et bonenfant, malgré la raison
pour laquelle la communauté
s'est rassemblée.
Plusieurs centaines de
personnes ont tenu à se déplacer
ici pour rendre hommage,
non seulement au 215 enfants
dont les restes ont été
découverts jus c c c côté, maisà
leurs familles et aux survivants
de tous les pensionnats.
Racelle Kooy est porteuse
de calumet et elle était sur
le site, avant même le lever
du soleil, à 5 h.
RACELLE KOOY, porteuse calumet
- Bien auparavant que les médias
sont arrivés, on était là
vraiment pour prier pour
les enfants d'ici et d'ailleurs
pour vraiment les envoyer
avec les ancêtres.
- Laisser aller ces enfants
morts et les célébrer avec
les enfants bien vivants
d'aujourd'hui, c'est un geste
traditionnel pour aider
à la guérison.
Et ce qui aide aussi, c'est
l'onde de choc qu'a provoqué la
découverte des corps de enfants
de Kamloops et celle
des centaines d'autres enfants
partout au pays.
Le secret dévoilé, de
nombreuses personnes en onté é e
réflexion, même la gouverneure
générale.
Entre les rires, les jeux
d'enfants et la musique parfois
festive, il y a, évidemment, des
larmes. Parce que la souffrance
reste vive, un an plus tard.
Mais la journée d'aujourd'hui
prouve que la communauté
se tient et s'entraide.
Avec l'aide du reste du Canada,
il y a l'espoir qu'elle puisse
un jour panser ses blessures.
Ici Julie Landry,
Radio-Canada, Tk'emlúps